[Music]
embalming students have to understand
the importance that every face is
different Morgan Freeman square face
Abraham Lincoln oblong face Kanye West
oval face my name is James Edward Smith
jr. I'm an instructor and clinical
director at Dallas Institute a funeral
service and I currently instruct
restorative art restorative art class
provides a skill set to be able to take
a deceased person who has experienced
trauma to the head and/or face and
restore those features in that face so
that the family may have an option for
an open casket viewing or visitation in
a fifth quarter the students are tasked
with reproducing a sculpture of a person
that they choose and the anatomy has to
be accurate students generally picked
celebrities you know they're popular
faces and students tend to want to try
to recreate those from our restorative
art project I did Jennifer Aniston Jack
white
Viola Davis Frieda calif i decided to do
david lynch
taking on the assignment requires each
of the students to understand the
proportions for the features of the face
here in school because it translates to
what may happen in the actual
preparation room
it is an acquired skill the more you
practice the more proficient the better
you're going to become the expectation
of the family is that this is something
we can sometimes do right away but we
have to take into account the amount of
trauma that the face has sustained we
need to have as much care when handling
the deceased as if they were in the
hospital under the care of a doctor I am
very passionate about restorative art
because I believe it's important for
people to have the best memory picture
possible when it's time to say goodbye
we're tasks as in Bombers to help
families have the option no matter the
cause of death to say goodbye to mom or
dad or brother or sister
[Music]
faces are the most important subject
matter in art it's a never-ending source
of material when you put on one of my
masks you become somebody different you
start to embody that character and have
a lot of fun with it
my name is Landon Meyer and I make
disturbingly realistic masks I never
thought I was gonna make a living doing
masks I was a picture framer loan
officer pizza delivery driver and then I
got laid off I've always been interested
in doing something that's like really
surreal and nightmarish so it was more
or less an experiment that took off I am
the only person out there that's doing
hyper realistic lightness masks I'm kind
of this weird mad scientist down in the
basement I start off getting lots of
reference material the hardest part is
doing the sculpture that can take
anywhere from four days to a year but
once the sculpt is done and I have a
mold it's about a one week process to
make a mask
they were ungodly expensive they ranged
$500 and up and sometimes even high as
$7,500 over the years I've made
approximately 25 different designs and
I've produced with my own hands over a
thousand masks
what I make I like to consider wearable
art these are super realistic sculptures
you can put over your head and where
people just seem to have this astonished
reaction to masks that's what I love
about him it was a dark time for Star
Wars when CG characters started popping
into every corner of the series but
before George R stumbled into our
collective consciousness
Star Wars was all about puppets which
brings us to this guy I'm Dave Barclay
I'm a puppeteer and puppet builder an
animatronic effects supervisor
you might recognize Dave better under
200 pounds of fiberglass and latex
because he was one of the puppeteers
inside Jabba the Hutt but to play the
most notorious gangster on Tatooine you
got to start somewhere and Dave well he
got his big break with a little green
man
[Music]
Notah was famously puppeteered by Frank
Oz the legend behind Cookie Monster and
Grover show you here and far but Yoda
was a complicated puppy and it took four
to five people working different body
parts to bring him to life Dave's job
was controlling Yoda's eyes and ears
there's a sequence when Yoda is flooding
mark with a stick saying where he was
what he was doing and I'm doing a little
squint and and subtle control on the
eyes yep right there that's me doing the
eyes there towards the end of the
filming on Empire Strikes Back Frank Oz
was performing Yoda and it became clear
if he'd had to move on to another film
and he wasn't going to be available so
they needed someone to take over from
Yoda and Frank nominated me I was 19
years old so suddenly there I am with
with Yoda even a 19 years old
Dave's Yoda scenes blended perfectly
with Frank Oz that was Dave did you guys
see that let's take one more Dave did
such a good job they called him back and
asked him to run a new puppet called
jabba the hutt jabba the hutt was
probably the most complicated and
sophisticated animatronic puppet that
anyone had ever tried to build and it
took six to seven people to operate
inside Jabba was very claustrophobic
very close one person doing the left
hand the head movement and the tongue
another puppeteer doing the mechanical
tail another puppeteer doing the
breathing on the air bladders I did
Jabba's right hand and I did his jaw and
then I provided the voice onstage my
voice doesn't make it to scream but if
you turned up on set will hear this sort
of voice where's my talk as a child they
weren't really any movies that had
puppeteers in them there was a little
bit here and there but there were no
solid characters like Yoda and being
part of the Yoda team which really was
the first performance animatronic in
movies was the start of this huge growth
that lasted about twenty years and as a
puppeteer and the puppet maker and
someone who loves the movies it was I
was in there exactly the right place at
the right time
I've had a wonderful career doing what I
adore so I'd feel very lucky and
privileged
[Music]
was our first feature of Point Break did
we do that before rumors not officially
yet right so as a company tremors would
be the first technically the cash future
but gasps I don't know
someone should Google that are you going
to ask us questions or did you want us
to start talking did you introduce each
other I would love to I would like to
introduce you to Tom Woodruff jr. who is
the co-founder of amalgamated dynamics
I'd like to introduce you to Alec Gillis
he's the co-founder of avi home of the
oscar-winning creature effects team when
people think of practical effects
creatures you think of non
computer-generated characters we've been
lucky to be involved with some of the
biggest and best of those types of
monsters we did the worms and tremors we
did the fat makeups of Tim Allen in the
Santa Clause all the practical animals
in Jumanji we've done the alien we've
done the predator with our ship troopers
I wasn't done you can keep going buddy
and of course there's always the gorilla
cut right now that's perfect right now
we cut putting the gorilla costume we
started performing own creatures because
we both have this sort of observation of
stuntmen despite their talents and their
skills them going into a creature suit
and not really knowing how to make a
creature suit work I would be very weird
for us to just say we're gonna build
something and then bring it to set and
say now what are you hungry that's some
foodie you hungry if you're a digital
animator you build the character and you
follow through and you make it move and
you bring it to life so that's our
philosophy is the final step is
performance because that's where it
lives you want to try a little tiny
piece here go ahead
what do you think you want some more hey
hey hey listen listen I could get you
fresh bread I could I could get you
fresh bread tremors is an example of a
film that was from the pre-digital era
and if you look at it the practical
effects they've stood the test of time
and we're proud of them digital effects
can do things that we can't possibly do
practical effects have a presence to
them that even the best CGI work gets
close to but doesn't completely achieve
in other words there's more emotion I
believe to a practical creature than to
a digital creature
wave to the camera and say goodbye bye
bye bye
[Music]
he's so temperamental